well we're going to get more information
very soon on how lethal this is and
whether it's susceptible to the vaccines
we now have but i think we've been right
to say everybody should be getting
vaccinated where possible everybody
should be tested where there's a risk
and that's true of our country but it
must be true of the rest of the world as
well and particularly africa so few
people have been vaccinated only seven
percent
so few have been tested hardly any tests
are being done in africa so you don't
detect things quickly enough so when the
g7 ministers meet this morning they
should agree that they will coordinate a
month-by-month plan to get vaccines out
to africa and to help them get testing
equipment and when the world health
assembly meets which is this morning
they should agree on a new uh treaty so
that we can prevent pandemics and deal
with them properly in the years to come
i did speak to the government minister
this morning the health minister in fact
and he was saying that you know we have
sent as part of the kovacs scheme we
have sent vaccines to africa and other
parts of the world and we will continue
to do that and we'll be up to about a
third of the level that we've committed
to very soon
i don't think that's strictly correct i
mean boris johnson said on
saturday that britain was leading the
way
we offered 100 million vaccines we've
provided only 11 of them so far
america has offered a billion vaccines
and provided 25 percent and even that's
not enough so britain's records not very
good and when boris johnson said on
saturday that the real problem in africa
was that people were not taking up the
vaccines
he was wrong because the real problem in
africa the biggest problem is the lack
of supply and as soon as we could get
the supply out to africa then i'm pretty
sure that the countries that have been
identified as red spots by the british
government
we can get vaccines into people's arms
it doesn't help us when there has been a
collective failure to get vaccines out
to everybody in the world you know
low-income countries it's three percent
britain it's nearly 70 percent what a
difference despite the fact that
everybody should have access to this
vaccine
and dr congo is 0.6 uh fully vaccinated
i think i was reading this morning
former prime minister world health
assembly uh getting underway today it's
a three-day
session examining global preparedness
and responses you know what is it that
you want to come out of that
well there should have been far better
early warning systems
there should also have been a far better
exchange of medical goods when people
were in difficulty and of course there
should have been equity in the
distribution of vaccines all these
should have happened and i think what
the world health assembly should do is
say look we want what you might call a
pandemic non-proliferation treaty we
want to prevent this happening in future
we've got to act now of course and get
the vaccines out but we've got to be
prepared for further variance and for
further
outrage outbreaks and we don't want them
to become pandemic so let's have a new
treaty where each country binds itself
to take the early action that should
have been taken and should still be
taken when it comes to vaccines
so what should we be doing to try to
protect the british public though as
well do we literally need to pull up the
drawbridge every time we hear about a
new variant
look um i i've been very clear speaking
on behalf of the world health
organization in this instance
that we've got to get vaccines out to
the rest of the world and there are
probably about 100 million vaccines in
the west that will be wasted by the end
of the year because they're not going to
be used and i think people hate waste
and hate the idea that vaccines will
pass their expiry date and not be used
as far as britain is concerned i had you
interviewing angela rainer and the
health minister already today and what
they're saying is absolutely right
you've got to act quickly
in september i think the sage committee
recommended the wider use of masks that
has got to come in obviously
and people have got to take the advice
about hand washing the social distancing
and so on if we're going to avoid some
of the problems that came last christmas
this christmas and of course if we're
going to avoid this going into the new
year we've got to take this early action
it's pretty clear that that's what's
necessary
so a couple of things to unpack their
former prime minister first of all as
far as masks are concerned the
government says you don't need to wear a
mask in england if you are in a pub or
in a restaurant obviously if you're
eating drinking of course you're not
going to but what about if you're
standing at the bar if you're in
scotland of course you know that you do
do you think that that's something the
government should be looking at again
well i think that advice is probably
going to change in the next few few days
i've always been very careful not to
second-guess the medical advice but i
think the medical advice from september
has been pretty clear about the wider
use of masks
and of course we now have some cases in
scotland this this morning as well as
cases in england uh from the weekend and
i think people will be far more vigilant
in future and will be wearing massive
from tomorrow of course uh in england uh
there's new laws that will require
people to do so in public transport uh
and if they're in shops and as far as
pcr tests are concerned the government
again decided that they weren't
necessary uh when people were either two
days before you came back to the uk or
indeed the two days after you were back
in the uk didn't need them uh anymore do
you think those should be reintroduced
as a matter of course i'm talking
particularly about the ones in order to
get into the uk
yes i think this this issue about taking
tests before you come to the uk will
come to the fore again when the g7
health ministers meet this morning there
probably should be a collective
agreement uh that will all do roughly
the same things when we're worried about
this you know that japan has already
closed flights you know that israel's
already done it morocco has already done
it
so you're going to have different
countries acting in different ways and a
lot of confusion it might be better if
the g7 could agree a collective approach
to what you do about testing before you
come to a particular country and of
course testing once you come in into a
country but you know the general point i
want to make is that
if we're talking about things that must
be done in the united kingdom and i
agree get vaccinated if you haven't been
vaccinated get testing if you haven't
been test tested and you think there is
a problem
then that advice must apply to the whole
of the world otherwise this disease will
continue to spread somewhere else it
will continue to mutate and it will come
back to haunt us even the fully
vaccinated if we haven't taken action in
other countries where the disease is
spreading some of those countries
particularly southern african countries
are saying by the time we get these
vaccines that you've promised us the the
shelf life is so short on them they're
useless and we can't have a a campaign
uh concerted advertising campaign to
make sure people do get vaccinated there
is a consideration a thought that
actually the um use by date on these
vaccines is just too short is that
something that should be looked at again
yeah that that is a real problem because
we talk about leftovers when you've got
extra vaccines you get them out but
probably at the last minute uh to the
countries that are needing them the
better way is to think look we're
producing soon two billion vaccines a
month across the world there's going to
be no difficulty about countries being
able to get hold of them if they're rich
enough to be able to afford them over
the next few months if we have excess
supply and we know we're not going to
use them in the next few months then we
should get them out as quickly as
possible this is all about coordination
uh if the g20 the group of richest
countries could agree that they would
have a coordinator so that we had a
month by month plan then we would not
run the same risk of a hundred million
vaccines being simply wasted now if you
waste a vaccine you're actually putting
a life at risk because that vaccine
could have been a life-saving uh it's
something that could have saved lives in
in another country if not our own
yeah and and just as i'm talking to you
hearing from the scottish deputy first
minister saying that there's no travel
history in some of the cases of the
omicron variant that have just been
discovered in scotland that would
suggest
perhaps it didn't originate in south
africa
well we know now that the first um
news of uh of a potential problem was
november the 11th
and i think it was in botswana and and
we will find more in the next few days
about where this originated what its
lethality is as well as how
transmissible it is so we need that
medical expertise luckily we've got one
of the best sequencing operations in the
united kingdom to enable us to do this
and south africa is cooperating in a way
that has been uh helpful to getting to
the bottom of this so i i do believe
we'll find out more information in the
next few days and of course the key
question is is the vaccine that is in
our arms or coming into our arms are
going to be able to cope with this new
variant and i certainly hope and i think
everybody will hope that it can